[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna büchs herzlich willkommen und
einen guten abend spannendes vom tennis
und vom fußball gibt es von norbert
lehmann war von mir und wir schauen
heute unter anderem auf einen der
höhepunkte im bundestag die
generaldebatte
märz contra scholz dem oppositionsführer
ist der ukraine kurs des kanzlers viel
zu zögerlich der kontakt in der
generaldebatte und kündigt weitere
waffenlieferungen an
billiger tanken billiger bahnfahren ab
heute zeigt sich im realitäts check ob
die angekündigten entlastungen
reibungslos anlaufen
und eine unvergessliche nacht so
schwärmt rafael nadal vor seinem sieg
bei den french open morgens kurz nach
eins novak djokovic ist raus im
halbfinale wartet alexanders im
bundestag heute scharfe attacken aus der
opposition kam es dass scholz parierte
lebhaft wie selten es war generaldebatte
dabei ging es vor allem um zwei große
themen die lieferung schwerer waffen an
die ukraine und die derzeit hohen preise
die der kanzler die inflation in den
griff kriegen will macht darüber
sprechen wir gleich mit unserer
korrespondentin vorher britta
spiekermann über den schlagabtausch
bundeskanzler scholz gibt sich gelassen
doch es gibt viel stoff für streit die
union übt scharfe kritik scholz
beschworenen zeitenwende nach
kriegsbeginn sei verpufft auch
versprochene waffen warte die ukraine
immer noch mehr als einen monat nach
dieser gemeinsamen entschließung im
deutschen bundestag sind der ukraine bis
zum heutigen tag die zugesagten waffen
nicht geliefert worden und sie herr
bundeskanzler reden in letzter zeit
etwas mehr als sonst aber sie sagen
unverändert nichts das was hier
vorgetragen hat sind lauter fragen sie
sind hier durch die sache durch
getänzelt und haben nichts konkretes
gesagt moabit wäre wirklich sehr
verdächtig gewesen märz spricht von
ansehensverlust und führungsschwäche
scheut geht in die offensive kündigte
überraschend weitere militärische hilfe
für die ukraine an zum beispiel hat die
bundesregierung aktuell entschieden dass
wir mit dem system iris t das modernste
flugabwehrsystem liefern über das
deutschland verfügt damit versetzen wir
die ukraine in die lage eine ganze
großstadt vor russischen luftangriffen
zu schützen auch das ist eine
entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
um diese entscheidungen machte man sich
nicht leicht sagt der grüne
koalitionspartner aber putin dürfe den
krieg nicht gewinnen
wir nehmen die sorgen und nöte und
ängste vor einer ausweitung des krieges
sehr ernst auch wir hadern manchmal auch
wir wägen ab und ja vielleicht könnten
manche entscheidungen auch schneller
getroffen werden die inflation das
zweite große thema die regierung will
sich zügig mit arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften zusammensetzen eine so
genannte konzertierte aktion gegen
preissteigerungen schon jetzt sollen
tank rabatt 9 euro ticket energie geld
entlasten das reicht nicht sagt die
linkspartei hier braucht es dringend
eine wirksame staatliche preisaufsicht
für lebensmittel energie damit schluss
ist mit den mondpreisen die afg spricht
von regierungsversagen die krise sei
nicht vom himmel gefallen die
verantwortung dafür könne man nicht
allein auf putins angriffskrieg schieben
inflation
ein explodierender energiepreise sind
die folge politischer
fehlentscheiden die inflation und der
krieg in der ukraine schwierige themen
in krisenzeiten heute mit einem kanzler
so offensiv wie lange nicht
ein offensiver kanzler also der auch
ankündigte die inflation zur chefsache
zu machen chacon teller banerjee eine
sogenannte konzertierte aktion will
scholz was hat aber genau vor also noch
ist das ganze offensichtlich nicht mehr
als eine überschrift denn wir hören aus
dem kanzleramt die einladungen sollen
erst in den nächsten tagen raus gehen an
arbeitnehmer und arbeitgeber und die
könnten dann in großer runde zum
beispiel über das sprechen wo vor der
finanzminister seit ein paar monaten
schon warnt nämlich die lohn preis
spirale also dass sich steigende preise
und steigende löhne gegenseitig
hochschaukeln und dadurch die inflation
noch weiter verschärfen diese runde wird
dabei übrigens nicht unter sich sein
haben auch aus kanzleramts kreisen
erfahren dass bundeskanzler scholz dort
selber mit am tisch sitzen möchte das
signal dürfte also lauten er macht
inflationsbekämpfung zur chefsache beim
anderen großen thema heute in der
generaldebatte der lieferung schwerer
waffen an die ukraine wird dem kanzler
ja immer wieder ja vorgeworfen zu
zögerlich zu sein jetzt hat er neue
waffenlieferung angekündigt wird die
kritik damit jetzt verstummen wie
schätzen sie das ein also darauf sollte
urlaub scholz nicht hoffen denn er hat
heute zwar einige erwartungen erfüllt
indem er die lieferung modernster
verteidigungstechnik für die ukraine in
aussicht gestellt hat aber da gibt es
noch einen haken und das ist die
lieferzeit das hat die außenministerin
heute auch im bundestag noch einmal klar
gestellt und hat damit wahrscheinlich
versucht erwartungen zu dämpfen annalena
baerbock sagte dort vor dem versammelten
plenum das wird dauern und zwar monate
also es ist nicht so dass jetzt mit
dieser technik sich die ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer sofort werden verteidigen
können da wird noch eine wartezeit vor
ihnen liegen und das wird dann sicher
auch wieder kritiker auf den plan rufen
für samstag unterleib energy aus berlin
in der generaldebatte hat der kanzler
der ukraine also weitere schwere waffen
versprochen wir wollen daher mal schauen
welche waffen überhaupt bisher geliefert
wurden und welche noch geliefert werden
sollen andreas huppert mit einem
überblick
iris t ist ein boden gebundenes
luftverteidigungssystem mittlerer
reichweite so die militärische exakte
bezeichnung für das was deutschland
jetzt der ukraine liefern will das
system der deutschen waffenschmiede deal
hier im werbevideo zählt zu der momentan
modernsten mobilen luftabwehr die
ukrainische armee soll damit in die lage
versetzt werden sich effektiver gegen
die angriffe russische flugzeuge
hubschrauber raketen und drohnen
verteidigen zu können neben iris gibt es
die zusage aus bundeswehrbeständen auch
mars zwei raketenwerfer zu liefern
insgesamt vier stück dazu ein modernes
ortungs radar um feindliche
artilleriestellungen aufklären zu können
drei weitere waffensysteme aus
deutschland für die ukraine also neben
den schon versprochenen 7
panzerhaubitzen und 50 flugabwehr panzer
vom typ gebhard wann geliefert wird noch
unklar schon in der ukraine angekommen
sind luftabwehrraketen panzerfäuste und
millionen schuss munition
ansonsten setzt die bundesregierung
weiter auf den sogenannten ringtausch
dabei liefern nato verbündete wie
slowenien oder tschechien panzer aus
sowjetischer produktion an die ukraine
im gegenzug erhalten sie dann deutsches
gerät wie den schützenpanzer marder auch
mit griechenland ist ein solcher
ringtausch laut bundeskanzler scholz
bereits fest vereinbart
die usa wollen der ukraine jetzt moderne
mehrfach raketenwerfer liefern aus dem
weißen haus hieß es die ukraine habe
zugesichert damit keine ziele in
russland anzugreifen der kreml warnt die
modernen raketensysteme würden öl ins
feuer gießen die ukrainische truppen
geraten im osten des landes immer
stärker unter druck lohans ist offenbar
nur noch eine statt vollständig unter
ukrainischer kontrolle ein bericht von
nina niebergall
nur wenige harren noch aus musik tanz
sie bereiten sich auf den russischen
großangriff vor dass der kommen wird
daran zweifelt hier kaum noch jemand
die das hier tun sind mörder das ist
kein krieg an den frontlinien das ist
ein krieg mit zivilisten der dazu führt
dass städte zerstört werden und alles
leben
den rauch über vierjähriger netz können
sie von hier aus sehen die nachbarstadt
auf der anderen seite des flusses ist
laut ukrainischen angaben fast
vollständig eingenommen
wenn die russen der 23 tagen die volle
kontrolle über das erkläre donetzk haben
werden sie danach anfangen dass sie
tanzt und artillerie beschuss zu nehmen
ins leere netz konnte sie klebten vor
dem krieg jeweils etwa 100.000 menschen
werden sie eingenommen ist du hans im
donbass komplett unter russischer
kontrolle beziehungsweise das was von
der region übrig ist die russischen
artillerieangriffe hinterlassen eine
spur der verwüstung
auch eine chemiefabrik soll getroffen
worden seien diese rote wolke offenbar
salpetersäure
wer dafür verantwortlich ist lässt sich
nicht überprüfen
angesichts der groß angelegten
chemieproduktion in the air oder netz
ist der russische beschuss die blinden
bombenangriffe vollkommen verrückt
in musik tanz sind nur noch die die
nicht weg können hier leben ist fast
unmöglich geworden
es gibt kein gas oder wasser oder strom
oder so etwas und humanitäre helfer sind
auch keine mehr da
eine geisterstadt in der ukrainische
soldaten weiter die stellung halten
zumindest noch
und für uns in der ukraine in odessa ist
johannes hano johannes heißt das denn
die ukraine kann den don was wohl gar
nicht mehr halten
also sieht tatsächlich so aus dass die
russischen truppen in bonn was den die
oberhand gewinnen werden und es gibt ja
schon spekulationen dass es einer
taktischen rückzug der ukrainischen
einheiten geben wird um eine
einkesselung zu entgehen die der
vollständigen vernichtung gleichkommen
präsenz lynskey hat gesagt man hat im
moment nicht die modernen waffen die man
bräuchte um diesen krieg zu gewinnen und
es gibt ja überall immer wieder die
vermutung dass der westen zögerlich nur
liefert um einnahmen kalkül putin ein
sieg im don bosco zugestehen im gegenzug
für eine waffenruhe aber dieses kalkül
werde nicht aufgehen putin werde nicht
aufhören er werde dass die eine
waffenruhe lediglich dazu nutzen um
seine truppen weiter aufzurüsten um sie
neu auszurüsten und dann richtung süden
zu schicken damit sie dann auf odessa
marschieren der hat ja immer gesagt er
will die ukraine vom seezugang
abschneiden und dafür muss auch deshalb
kontrollieren der tenor hier ist eine
waffenruhe im donbass sollten sie
irgendwann kommen wird den krieg in der
ukraine und europa nicht beenden aus der
ukraine johannes hano dankeschön
ja und die wirtschaftlichen folgen des
krieges sind längst auch in deutschland
spürbar allen voran die inflation helfen
soll ja ein entlastungspaket heute ging
es los mit dem tank rabatt und dem mon
euro bahnticket darüber berichten wir
gleich im juli soll es für jedes kind
einen 100 euro bonus geben und für hartz
iv empfängerinnen und empfänger einmalig
200 euro und wohl ab september eine
energiepreis pauschale von 300 euro
jetzt also der tank rabatt sind die
preise an den zapfsäulen wirklich
gesunken stefan wachs halb zwei in der
nacht eine tankstelle in leipzig
tatsächlich die zwei vor dem komma ist
weg brandenburg kurz nach mitternacht
auf der einen seite die alten preise auf
der anderen benzin und diesel um einen
euro 90 vielerorts auch darunter wie er
in dieser hamburger tankstelle ist der
blick auf die preistafel nicht mehr ganz
so schmerzhaft
das ist unglaublich für mich jede woche
15 euro sparen kann ist das für mich
natürlich eine super sache die
ungewissheit bleibt natürlich trotzdem
ob das ganze jetzt längerfristig ist
experten hatten erwartet dass die preise
an den tankstellen erst später fallen
weil zuvor noch mit dem höheren
steuersatz erworbener kraftstoff
verkauft werden muss gerade freie
tankstellen die der frau in der
preisgestaltung sind die also jetzt
frischeres prinzip nach getankt haben
sie können den preis natürlich dann auch
schneller weiter geben mit tank apps
könne man teils größere
preisunterschiede zwischen benachbarten
tank denn vergleichen rät der adac
unwahrscheinlich sei es dass in den
nächsten tagen auch die gesamte für drei
monate geplante senkung der energie
steuern von mehr als 35 cent für e10
super benzin und fast 17 cent für diesel
weitergegeben wird der günstigere
kraftstoff lockte aber heute schon viele
an die zapfsäulen und mancherorts
bildeten sich wie hier in leipzig erste
autoschlangen
und ab heute gilt auch dass neun euro
ticket bedeutet für neun euro pro monat
kann man bundesweit den ganzen
nahverkehr nutzen über den staat markus
weise fahren
viele haben es bereits das neun euro
ticket rund sieben millionen mal wurde
es bisher verkauft viel mobilität für
wenig geld reisende und pendler wie hier
in frankfurt am main mit gemischten
gefühlen für die nächsten tage und
wochen ich
glaube dass die menschen nicht umsteigen
günstiger kann man nicht anfahren das
ticket gibt es jeweils für juni juli und
august online am schalter oder am
automaten es gilt bundesweit in bussen
straßenbahnen s- und u-bahnen sowie in
den meisten zügen des nah und
regionalverkehrs nicht jedoch im
fernverkehr also ece intercity und
eurocity
wir haben
bei personal bei infrastruktur bei
kapazitäten und von daher ist das auf
jeden fall immer wieder ein kraftakt
klimafreundliche mobilität ohne tarif
grenzen eine tolle idee findet der vater
ist verband pro bahn er warnt jedoch vor
überfüllten zügen und fordert er
langfristige konzepte
ob das die leute allerdings dauerhaft in
den plv bringt wenn es im september
wieder heißt die normalerweise müssen
bezahlt werden das lasse ich jetzt mal
dahingestellt
vereinzelt wie hier in leipzig war schon
einiges los insgesamt aber ein
unspektakulärer start für das 9 euro
ticket kann es neun euro ticket der
start zu einer verkehrswende sein
darüber diskutiert zdf heute live mit
verkehrsminister volker wissing gleich
um 19.25 in der zdf- heute- app und auf
unseren social media kanälen
vor dramatischen engpässen den
kinderkliniken warnen ärzteverbände
wegen personalmangels könne auf vielen
kinder intensivstationen ein drittel der
betten nicht genutzt werden so die
vereinigung der intensiv und
notfallmedizin divi und im herbst wenn
die üblichen infektionswellen kommen
dürfte sich die lage noch verschärfen
seit jahren bemüht sich kroatien um die
aufnahme den kreis der euro-länder jetzt
hat die eu kommission grünes licht dafür
gegeben das land will seine währung kuna
im kommenden jahr durch den euro
ersetzen kroatien ist seit juli 2013
mitglied der europäischen union große
erwartungen hat die tourismusbranche an
die euro-einführung auf der anderen
seite fürchten viele menschen in
kroatien dass durch die gemeinsame
währung die lebenshaltungskosten stark
steigen werden und jetzt schauen wir ins
vereinigte königreich die queen überall
selbst auf den riesigen steinquadern des
stonehenge monuments elisabeth die
zweite feiert nämlich ihr 70
thronjubiläum und ein bisschen auch
ihren geburtstag nach vier tage lang
steigt eine gigantische party gast den
herrlein bringt uns schon mal in
stimmung
so hat man sich das morgen vorzustellen
die traditionelle militärparade trooping
the colour die jedes jahr anlässlich des
geburtstags der queen stattfindet
diesmal wahrscheinlich noch prächtiger
zum siebzigsten thronjubiläum ihrer
majestät zu bieten hat hoch zu ross
schon mal geübt
queen gitarrist brian may der beim
goldenen thronjubiläum 2002 der königin
gewissermaßen aufs dach stieg kündigte
an dass er diesmal wieder eine
überraschung parat hat beim großen
konzert am samstag wird jede menge
prominenz vertreten sein
es wird leuchtfeuer geben und einen
gedenkgottesdienst in der st pauls
kathedrale und na ja jede menge junin 6
im britischen frühsommer wind freunde
des royalen haben sich schon jetzt in
den parks und entlang der pracht straßen
rund um den buckingham-palast versammelt
wir sind hier die queen zu unterstützen
und zu zeigen dass wir royal fans sind
ich liebe die queen einfach ich bin
stolz auf sie
und die hauptfigur endlich meldet sich
königin elizabeth die zweite nach vielen
gesundheitlichen rückschlägen und einem
äußerst turbulenten anflug aus vellmar
fit genug den feiermarathon zu ihrem
thron jubiläum durchzustehen und
er norbert der hat ganz ganz leichte
augenringe heute aber wirklich nur ganz
leicht weil du euch die nacht vor dem
fernseher verbracht hat weil es bei den
french open so super stand gar nicht mit
ins bett gekommen aber die maske hat
hervorragend gearbeitet ja das über
vierstündigen aktuell zwischen rafael
nadal und titelverteidiger novak
djokovic das dauerte bis 1 uhr 15 der
spanier siegte und trifft im halbfinale
auf alexanders wäre der zuvor gegen
shooting star carlos alcaraz gewann
emotion tour bei alexander zverev nach
dem sieg es ist 12 bestes tennis in
diesem jahr sein gegner alcaraz 14
spiele ungeschlagen hat das nachsehen
gegen den deutschen olympiasieger der
spanier zeigt ein spektakuläres spiel
doch der weltranglisten dritte knack das
ausnahmetalent beim 3 1-sieg mit einer
spielerischen top leistung steht wie im
vorjahr im halbfinale von paris
anschließend das topduell rafael nadal
gegen novak djokovic nadal gewinnt den
ersten satz mit 6 zu 2 doch der
titelverteidiger djokovic schlägt im
zweiten zurückdreht 1 0 zu 3 rückstand
und gleich nachsetzen aus auch hier geht
es im vierten durchgang in den tie-break
mit dem vierten match bei bezwingt nadal
djokovic nach mehr als vier stunden mit
321 freitag das halbfinale zwischen dem
spanier und der deutsche nummer eins
ein einziges europäisches ticket für die
fußball wm in katar ist noch zu vergeben
große hoffnung macht sich die ukraine
die heute abend in schottland im
halbfinale der play-offs antritt mit
fast dreimonatiger verspätung wegen des
russischen angriffskriegs
alexander schenk von manchester city
kann man sehen wie es um die
nationalmannschaft der ukraine bestellt
ist den träger der heimat im kopf die
füße auf dem rasen in schottland seit
monaten ohne chance auf eine wirklich
konkurrenzfähige vorbereitung
jeder ukraine möchte zunächst nur eines
dass der krieg aufhört im fußball haben
wir den traum von der wm wir wollen den
ukrainern diese unglaublichen emotionen
geben weil unser volk das gerade jetzt
besonders braucht
die fans beider teams geben sich in
glasgow wie vor einem freundschaftsspiel
die schotten wollen wie anderswo auch
schon die ukrainische hymne mitsingen
gewinnen will schottland aber auch der
sieger des abends spielt am sonntag das
finale in wales um die reise zur wm
ich weiß wem ich die daumen drücke das
war es von mir denken arbeiterinnen
schauen wir noch auf die lottozahlen von
diesen mittwoch die gewinnzahlen lauten
2 49 32 42 48 superzahl ist die neun
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
und was das wetter angeht es morgen noch
meist freundlich zum pfingstwochenende
allerdings stehen unwetter bevor was da
wo zu erwarten ist das erfahren sie
gleich von christa orden um 21 45 gibt
es das heute journal mit bettina
schausten ich sagt schütz
[Musik]
er bekommt mit diesem zwischenhoch hier
gibt es morgen in deutschland noch mal
viel sonne ab freitag dann punkt aber
ein tief von portugal schwül-heiße luft
zu uns und damit stehen uns unwetter
bevor schon heute gab es im norden ja
viele aber schwächere gewitter die
lassen jetzt in der nacht langsam nach
in den frühstunden bilden sich in
schleswig holstein noch mal neue schauer
der gewittriger regen sich der donau
auch der klingt in der nacht ab
dazwischen ist es oft klar bei örtlichem
nebel sinken die temperaturen auf 3 10
bis 3 grad große unterschiede gibt es
auch morgen da geht es im süden hinauf
auf 22 bis 27 grad im norden haben wir
15 bis 21 grad der norden kriegt morgen
aber insgesamt mal wieder mehr sonne ab
dann haben wir schauen nur noch im
küstenumfeld bei einem stark böigen wind
und nachmittags im südlichen
alpenvorland auch noch mal kurze schauer
und gewitter sonst gibt es am tag oft
große wolkenlücken am freitag und am
samstag geht es im norden des landes
dann auch mit freundlichem wetter und
angenehmen temperaturen weiter im
südwesten allerdings am samstag dann
auch in der mitte und im südwesten da
kommt dieses schwüle luft bis 30 grad an
in der eben heftige gewitter mit
starkregen und hagel dabei sein kann und
auch über die pfingstfeiertage bleibt
die gefahr von unwettern bestehen
tschüss